bonjour merci d'être là ça fait plaisir
bonjour madame Richie alors un compromis
évidemment tout le monde sait ce que ça
veut dire ça veut dire que personne est
complètement satisfait qu'est-ce qui
vous apparaît être la plus grande
victoire pour la Cour du Québec est-ce
que je veux pas vous suggérer une
réponse mais pas en terme de d'argent ou
de personnes mais est-ce que c'est la
reconnaissance du fait que les juges
travaillent maintenant davantage ou que
leur travail c'est compliqué en fait je
pense que la plus grande victoire c'est
davantage pour l'ensemble des
justiciables et les citoyens du Québec
pour que cette réforme qu'on a mis en
place quant à la réorganisation du
travail des juges se fasse dans un
contexte transitoire alors c'est surtout
ça et histoire dans le sens de ça va
mener à autre chose dans le sens que
actuellement
l'entente porte sur trois ans où nous
allons ajouter à la nouvelle politique
d'assignation les juges vont siéger on
va demander les jeux sont d'accord pour
faire un effort additionnel de jour
additionnels par année judiciaire et
vous avez peut-être
c'est davantage lié aux difficultés
liées à l'enquête policière à la
communication de la preuve à des délais
qui sont imputables à toutes sortes
d'autres raisons que l'indisponibilité
des jetons pas nécessairement parce
qu'on y arrivait pas donc absolument pas
alors
est-ce que je peux vous garantir qu'il y
aura plus d'arêtes procédure en vertu de
jardin non parce qu'on n'a pas le
contrôle il y a beaucoup de choses qui
peuvent influencer les délais la
conduite de la poursuite dans le cadre
dans le cadre d'une instance judiciaire
la façon dont la preuve a été recueillie
par les policiers alors tout ne repose
pas sur les délais et la disponibilité
d'un juge pour entendre un dossier
évidemment bon les gens qui suivent les
affaires judiciaires et je les connais
ils sont nombreux mais je pense qu'il
soupçonnent pas tout le travail qui est
fait que ça suppose qu'est-ce qui a
particulièrement changé entre avant dans
mon temps et maintenant
c'est à dire ce qu'on appelle
l'évolution de la fonction du juge vous
savez -20 des jeux j'étais procureur de
la poursuite j'ai commencé à pratiquer
le droit criminel en 1980 avant la
Charte canadienne des droits et libertés
et à cette époque le juge avait
finalement qu'une seule décision à
rendre par dossier culpabilité le
jugement alors c'est le jugement parfois
l'occasion un jugement sur
l'admissibilité de la déclaration de
l'accusé à une personne en autorité avec
l'avènement de la Charte canadienne des
droits et libertés il y a eu beaucoup il
y a beaucoup plus de recettes des
requêtes qui sont dans le cadre du
procès qui qui où on Allègre la
violation à des droits qui sont garantis
par l'achat de sorte que chaque dossier
maintenant plusieurs dossiers amènent
souvent plus d'une plus qu'une seule
décision en cours de cours alors ça
c'est évidemment la complexification de
la preuve les moyens technologiques
toutes les communications technologiques
aujourd'hui et c'est la mise en preuve
de qui de
qu'on recueille ses moyens là soulève
aussi des débats pour ne donner qu'un
autre exemple mais on a fait une analyse
sérieuse de l'évolution de l'ensemble de
la fonction de juge il y a aussi
davantage il y a un autre élément aussi
c'est que avant le juge est un peu le
juge Sphinx maintenant le juge doit
préparer davantage en amont les requêtes
sont écrites il doit en prendre
connaissance la préparation du dossier
est plus en amont c'est à dire préalable
à l'audience et plus importante nous
faisons aussi des facilitations
alors des conférences de facilitation à
la demande des parties ou des
conférences de gestion imposées par la
Cour pour justement provoquer ce
changement de culture auquel l'arrêt de
Jordan nous a tous conviés pour aller un
petit peu plus vite fonction à évoluer
et il faut adapter l'organisation du
travail en fonction de cette évolution
évidemment une dernière question vos
positions étaient tellement loin l'une
de l'autre que il a fallu nommer un
médiateur le juge Chamberlin ça ce qui
montre bien que les juges peuvent faire
la conciliation on a lu son intervention
25000 dollars je sais pas combien ont
coûté les procédures intentées par le
ministre qui sont presque rendus à la
cour d'appel sachant qu'on vient la
confiance du public et fragile dans
l'institution
vous pensez pas que ça peut rendre les
gens un peu cynique cette bataille là
écoutez il saurait pas été souhaitable
mais aujourd'hui je pense que il faut
regarder vers l'avenir et se dire que
c'est une bonne nouvelle pour le système
judiciaire et que les mesures qui sont
mises en place ne remettront pas non
plus jamais en question malgré le suivi
rigoureux qu'on va faire des mesures en
place ne remettrons pas en question la
qualité des services au judiciables et
l'indépendance de la magistrature la
neutralité des juges parce que vous
savez les Justiciers qui se présentent
devant nous ne sont pas des statistiques
en effet ce sont des vrais conserver la
même façon de faire en effet Lucie
Rondeau merci infiniment d'être venu en
studio je vous en prie merci madame
monsieur au revoir pour voir nos
émissions en entier rendez-vous sur la
chaîne ici RDI